[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
récit de la vie des acteurs économiques
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et pour cette édition nous
sommes au coeur du pôle commercial paris
ouest à maurepas un pôle qui va célébrer
ses 50 ans l'année prochaine et qui est
en pleine transformation
114 commerce un hypermarché est une zone
de chalandise de plus de 260 mille
habitants est parmi les promoteurs
immobiliers l'entreprise éthique c'est
avec son projet sur vingt mille mètres
carrés c'est ce que je vous propose de
découvrir dans ce 26e numéro du sky est
qu un magasin vient d'ouvrir un mort pas
son nom d'abd grand marché vrac sur la
zone paris ouest son créateur laurent
sec nous raconte son histoire ce magasin
le signe du renouveau de la zone
commerciale paris-ouest nous
découvrirons l'avenir de ce pôle
d'activités avec l'entreprise
immobilière et ixia enfin l' agence
technitoit de coignard recrute des
couvreurs et des façadiers découverte de
ces métiers dans cette édition
1973 création de la zone d'activités à
l'époque édouard jo par le père
fondateur de paris ouest souhaite
développer une zone exclusivement
industriel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ixia fait partie des acteurs de
l'immobilier commercial présents ici sur
la zone de paris ouest et c'est ici
autour de nous qu'il bâtit à sa manière
le renouveau de ce pôle commercial
vingt mille mètres carrés avec des
enseignes des espaces verts et diverses
activités livraison prévue en 2024 ont
rejoint tout de suite la responsable de
ce projet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous la responsable du projet et
ixia sur la zone paris ouest géraldine
yolain bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors où en est on dans le projet
d'aménagement de cette zone alors sur le
projet donc on est en phase de
finalisation de la première phase de
renouvellement urbain dont qui a
consisté véritablement rénover
complètement et
donc en lecture d'aménagement toute la
zone dans cette première étape donc avec
vous allez des ouvertures dans scène qui
se sont ils sont ouverts depuis donc
septembre jusqu'à à peu près novembre
donc avec un étalement d'ouverture des
enseignes ce projet là donc dans cette
phase une a consisté véritablement à
retravailler tout la lisibilité urbaine
donc la façade commerciale de l' axe
principal avec une meilleure
accessibilité notamment et de visibilité
au niveau des enseignes pour la partie
commerciale
etc en deux faces finalement il ya ces
deux premiers bâtiments mais il y en a
un autre aussi qui m'apparaît très
exactement dans le prolongement donc une
deuxième phase va intervenir notamment
avec des onze juges des enjeux urbains
de coeur d'îlot à végétales notamment de
déambulation d'hyper mobilité donc une
alternative à la voiture donc sur cette
deuxième étape avec un vraiment un coeur
d'îlot une ambition parenthèse ouverte
sur ce projet là et là on est en plein
dans le futur des zones commerciales
exactement l'objectif est qu'elles ne
soient pas strictement définies comme
commercial puisque l'objectif est
véritablement travailler dès mixité
fonctionnelle donc des fonctions autre
que le commerce complémentaire au
commerce ça peut être par exemple ça
peut être du service a peut-être en
effet dû de l'habitat ça peut être
véritablement du loisir l'objectif est
véritablement que les fonctions se
nourrissent les unes par rapport aux
autres pour en faire vraiment une
lecture de territoire est une réponse
aux besoins du territoire et au-delà de
proposer des nouvelles activités qu'on
n'avait pas encore dans les zones
commerciales c'est aussi une offre de
commerces qui varient qui échangent
exactement l'objectif est aussi de créer
une vraie singularité et 1 et des
éléments différenciants donc deux zones
de zones notamment des espaces
commerciaux donc ça ça passe aussi par
un mixité en tout cas de deux typologies
de formats et de profils de commerce
avec des porteurs de projets locaux qui
vont être complémentaire aux enseignes
nationales et avec des tendances lourdes
duo la crise sanitaire qui était déjà
présente avant mais qui sont amplifiées
avec ceux ci ont renforcé l'objectif est
aussi sur les ambitions portées sur plus
sûr plus sur ce projet là c'est vraiment
travaillé notamment sur la partie
consommation valorisation de toutes les
richesses du territoire consommation
saine valorisation des circuits courts
donc on est vraiment sur cet enjeu la de
programmation complémentaire aux
enseignes nationales on travaille on met
en valeur toutes les richesses du
territoire et toutes les richesses
locaux locale par nom par rapport aux
bonds aux porteurs de projets qui vont
venir compléter les enseignes nationales
merci géraldine yolande rappelle que
vous êtes responsable du projet etics
assuré zone paris ouest et ixia
promoteur immobilier spécialisé dans les
espaces commerciaux et justement on va
aller voir le magasin day by day et son
créateur c'est un grand marché en vac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous le créateur de day by day
maurepas grand marché vrac laurent sec
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors vous avez ouvert le 13 octobre
comment ça se passe les premiers jours
ici écoutez le démarrage il est
incroyable
je suis j'attendais pas autant de monde
c'est évident donc on avait vraiment eu
un afflux de personnes mercredi jeudi
vendredi samedi bon j'avais fait un gros
tapage sur les réseaux les gens étaient
un peu curieux de mon histoire et voilà
il était en rendez vous donc on était en
très satisfait de ce démarrage alors
justement votre histoire parlons-en vous
étiez directeur commercial dans une
entreprise est aujourd'hui vous
retrouver à la tête d'un magasin à
preuve particulier puisque vous faites
du vrac tous les produits sont vendus en
vrac comment ça s'est fait tout ça une
prise de conscience pour moi parce que
j'étais directeur commercial
effectivement pendant 13 ans dans une
entreprise qui était un univers du
snacking premium donc super produit je
représentais 40 marques différentes mais
ont généré en vendait des produits le
snacking c'est les produits remporté
donc ils sont emballés sur emballés et
je me disais mais c'est pas possible
tous ces déchets qu'on produit alors
qu'on fait des supers produits c'est
frustrant donc voilà j'ai eu envie de
tourner la page et puis d'aller vers un
projet qui avait plus de sens pour moi
d'où cette idée autour du bras que je
connaissais débats et des depuis très
longtemps alors c'est un magasin qui est
particulier c'est quoi la philosophie de
ce magasin c'est rare en plus dans la
marque beats by dr effectivement c'est
le deuxième magasin
de ce format là il ya 75 des bd en
france mais ce sont des magasins de
centre-ville
épicerie droguerie hygiène les clients
ressortait des débats et des en disant
c'est génial mais on peut pas faire tout
nos courses puisqu'il ya pas les
produits frais donc on a été un peu plus
loin et le concept débats et des grands
marchés vrac y va c'est un débat et des
deux centres villes et qu'on installe en
périphérie et sur lequel on va rajouter
tous les produits frais avec des
commerçants engagé locaux qui m'ont
rejoint dans le projet pour défendre les
mêmes valeurs que celles que je voulais
porter avec des vagues alors justement
on est passé le fromage et le boucher le
maraîcher alors c'est qui qui sont
toutes ces personnes je suis vraiment
super fier d'avoir réussi à convaincre
ces gens qui m'ont accompagné je vais
commencer par le boucher donc la
boucherie cardié c'était vraiment un
message à envoyer aux mort passe bien
aussi de dire que la proximité et la
périphérie pouvait être complémentaires
donc la boucherie cardié c'est une
boucherie du centre ville de maurepas et
qui a rejoint le projet en plus de son
activité ensuite on a derrière vous
ludovic biseau meilleur ouvrier de
france qui a une activité à rambouillet
et qui m'a fait l'honneur de me
rejoindre dans le projet et ensuite
alors pour ludovic un petit moment le
les les produits c'est le terroir donc
c'est vraiment la volonté de proposer
une gamme qui correspond à chaque
terroir
[Musique]
et on peut le maraîcher alors et le
maraîcher ben on va avec cette offre de
produits fruits et légumes pouvoir aussi
surfer sur le souhait des gens d'avoir
aussi des produits locaux puisque l'un
on a une offre aujourd'hui un loft qui
dans le magasin elle est à plus de 60%
d'une provenance de moins de 80
kilomètres d'ici donc on est sur les
produits qui viennent majoritairement
des yvelines du val d'oise de l'oise
c'est de la culture pleine terre c'est
de la haute valeur environnementale et
notre maraîcher qui fait les marchés de
saint germain en laye chat ou son
leitmotiv c'est le goût le goût le goût
il dit les clients quand ils achètent
des fruits et légumes les produits se
conservent très très peu et en plus ils
ont plus de goût donc voilà on a essayé
et les retours qu'on a depuis mercredi
bas il ya déjà des gens qui sont venus
trois fois quatre fois en cinq jours
c'est étonnant et ils nous disent
vraiment les fruits et légumes sont
super bons donc voilà je suis vraiment
fier de les avoir tous convaincu de me
rejoindre et
bah on après c'est le début c'est les
premiers jours mais c'est très
encourageant et puis on espère que les
gens seront satisfaits par cette offre
merci laurent sec merci aux mouches est
bon courage dans cette aventure écoutez
du courage y en a et les gens me donnent
énormément d'énergie donc c'est vraiment
chouette et je rappelle donc que vous
êtes le créateur et dirigeant du débat
et démord pas grand marché vrac
[Musique]
et pour conclure sur le sujet du magasin
day by day à maurepas laurent sec a
lancé une campagne de financement
participatif objectif financer des
ateliers autour du potager que vous
voyez derrière moi et mais aussi des
ateliers autour des astuces anti
gaspillage rendez vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
le secteur du bâtiment connaît des
besoins en recrutement et c'est le cas
notamment de l'entreprise technitoit
située à coignières elle recherche
actuellement une vingtaine de personnes
10 couvreur et 10 façadier pour ses
chantiers c'est la séquence elles
recrutent
[Musique]
je m'appelle jean baptiste malvoisin je
suis actuellement coureur chez
technitoit dans les yvelines à
coignières j'ai 28 ans et je suis chez
technitoit depuis trois ans
[Musique]
notre activité consiste à la rénovation
de toitures donc ça peut être de
changement de voiture complète ou dans
la rénovation remplacement des tuiles
isolation changement de gouttière mais
on fait également la rénovation des
toitures par le système de nettoyage de
démoussage et diderot fut donc qui peut
être notés sur de la tulle béton
pour nous la couverture ce avant tout un
travail manuel c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait depuis longtemps on aime ça à
rénover les belles maisons comme comme
celle ci c'est un travail en extérieur
on est assez libre
[Musique]
1 c ap en maçonnerie suivi d'un cep de
couvreur et j'ai prolongé ma formation
par un brevet professionnel de
couverture pour ensuite être embauché
dans une entreprise comme couvreur
[Musique]
actuellement sur l' agence de coignières
on recherche une vingtaine de personnes
10 couvreur et 10 façadier à peu près on
recherche avant tout des cdi
on cherche évidemment des gens avec de
l'expérience sachant plaire tout type de
couverture comme tous types de façades
des gens sérieux motivé avec une envie
de l' envie d'apprendre rigoureux
avec un investissement personnel
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
m